posé dans la vallée du Cher à quelques
kilomètres de Saint-Amand-Montrond
l'abbaye de Noirlac
l'abbaye fut fondée au 12e siècle par un
petit groupe de one sisteriens dans
leurs besoins d'autarcie il construisent
en pied de colline bénéficiant des bois
alentours des prairies et dans le val
d'une terre riche ainsi que de l'eau
pour notamment installer des pêcheries
l'abbaye aujourd'hui centre culturel
travaille sur un projet d'aménagement
des jardins et du paysage environnant
fait de bocage
s'agit Clément ingénieur horticole
paysagiste écrivain et jardinier qui est
en charge du projet premier travail
étudier l'existant
il y a deux choses qui sont importantes
le paysage dans à sa grande échelle qui
va depuis le sommet de ses collines même
si elles sont modestes elles c'est un ce
sont des réels points hauts jusqu'au
cher qui englobe les visions complètes
en panoramique avec les constructions
avec les villes ça c'est vraiment des
choses dont on ne peut pas ne pas tenir
compte mais il y a aussi quelque chose
qui est fondamental et qui est la marque
du territoire à partir de l'abbaye
c'est-à-dire l'aspect historique
l'esprit ce que ça signifie donc est-ce
qu'on peut combiner les deux
à l'image de la vie ascétique des
cisterciens l'architecture de l'abbaye
est simple les jardins et aménagements
offrent cette même sobriété
le projet d'aménagement concerne le
cloître la basse-cour et la magnifique
allée de tilleul mais un nouveau tracé
d'accès au domaine vers le jour c'est
une passerelle haute qui a choisi Gilles
Clément pour un point de vue dégagé sur
l'abbaye et sur un ensemble de jardins à
venir
Gilles présente son travail pour la
première fois à Paul Fournier directeur
du lieu
et l'une des raisons importantes de la
modification de l'espace vient de la
nécessité d'entrer autrement et
c'est-à-dire d'entrer en réalité comme
sans doute on était entré autrefois par
une porte qui existe toujours moi je
connais je suis convaincu de
l'importance du premier regard quand on
arrive dans un endroit le regard jeté au
début dans au moment de la découverte et
décisive dans la dans l'approche qu'on
en aura ensuite et donc c'est vrai qu'il
fallait repenser cette approche qui est
effectivement aujourd'hui consultation
un peu étroite et la réponse est en
imaginant cet espace là
Gilles s'appuie sur un travail minutieux
de l'histoire de l'abbaye mais il ne
copie pas ne rejoue pas une partition du
passé il s'inspire
on fait appel à qui est un artiste qui a
ce regard artistique et c'était aussi
une raison que j'aurais pu évoquer tout
à l'heure mais comme Michael qui a pris
du président
au choix de faire appel à Gilles c'est
c'était cette dimension artistique qu'il
porte en lui la réflexion et le regard
artistique de Gilles vont par exemple
permettre de voir l'abbaye avant même
d'être entré sur le domaine grâce à un
système de jardin en antichambre l'acte
semble anodin pourtant il vient à
l'encontre du passé de l'abbaye lieu
plutôt clos à l'abri des regards le
travail de Gilles est aussi celui-ci
faire avancer les mentalités
on est dans un site d'origine religieuse
à une époque où le savoir la culture
était détenu par l'ensemble des
religieux en Europe et presque dans le
monde aujourd'hui on est dans un autre
monde il se trouve qu'on hérite que ce
patrimoine culturel bâtit remarquable et
que la culture y est transformé et
développé à l'intérieur mais pas
forcément en relation à la religiosité
ça peut être en relation autre chose
un lieu comme celui-ci il nous met en
isolement en déconnexion plutôt avec ce
qui se trouve de l'autre côté des murs
donc on est vraiment un peu comme un
espace de méditation tourné à la fois
vers soi-même ou vers
l'esprit l'exercice de la spiritualité
j'ai imaginé un jardin où on peut quand
même marcher mais on marche comme si on
marchait entre des plages de nuages mais
sauf que ce sont des plantes qui sont
évocatrices à floraison bleue pâle etc
gris enfin qui sont dans le reflet du
ciel comme tous les projets artistiques
de Noirlac ce projet d'aménagement est
porté par la volonté de mariée passer et
modernité avec une particularité
intervenir sur le paysage s'est accepté
de ne pas tout maîtriser
tout se transforme dans le temps moi je
sais pas ce qui va se passer dans le
futur j'en ai aucune espèce d'idée je
suis seulement que dans notre métier
nous ne pouvons pas ne pas prendre en
compte la dimension du temps nous
travaillons dans la durée c'est notre
objet principal le temps sauf qu'on tire
pas comme on le fait dans le stress
aujourd'hui
du management pas du tout ça n'a
absolument rien à voir on l'accompagne
on travaille avec en attendant que le
projet se réalise sur le terrain
l'abbaye invite Gilles Clémence cet été
pour une exposition intitulée toujours
la vie invente il livrera son regard de
jardinier humaniste et visionnaire porté
sur notre jardin partagé la planète mais
cela c'est une autre histoire